[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
football les championnats amateurs sont
définitivement arrêtée la fédération
française a annoncé cette décision la
semaine dernière pour lui parler de
cette actualité nous recevront en
plateau le président du district des
yvelines jean pierre meurillon golf coup
de projecteur dans ce magazine sur l'une
des futures stars du golf français
charlotte liothier du club de saint nom
la bretèche
elle vient de remporter les
internationaux d'italie dalle son
portrait à suivre dans quelques instants
cyclisme sur piste nous aurons également
le plaisir de recevoir benjamin thomas
trois fois champion du monde
le pistard qui s'entraîne régulièrement
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines devrait participer aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
on va tout de suite parlé un football
mercredi dernier la fédération française
a annoncé à l'arrêt de la saison pour
les amateurs ce sera donc une saison
blanche les compétitions amateurs sont
donc arrêtés pour la deuxième année
consécutive pour nous parler de cette
actualité nous avons avec nous en
plateau jean pierre me rayon président
du district des vignes de football bon
soir alors est ce que c'est une surprise
ou pas du tout non c'est pas une
surprise on s'attendait malheureusement
à ce qu'une décision soit prise dans ce
sens la seule question j'étais depuis ya
un mois ou deux c'était de savoir quand
la décision je prendrais lien d'être
prise je pense que ça permet de savoir
maintenant comment comment la saison va
se terminer
est ce que c'est une décision logique
vous savez il ya plusieurs hypothèses
qui avaient été envisagées pour terminer
la saison alors éventuellement ne faire
que des matches aller par exemple faire
des play-offs des play-down après et
c'est bon pichat que chaque semaine qui
passe et faisait cuire des moines dates
qui étaient encore disponibles et il
arrive un moment où le nombre de dates
disponibles n'est plus suffisant pour
que les la compétition se termine est-ce
que vous avez été jusqu'au bout nous
toutes les solutions est ce que tout a
été analysé pendant de longues semaines
langue de l'ombre à tout à fait la
fédération a beaucoup consulté les
présidents des ligues les présidents des
stries que les clubs
il fallait que ça il fallait qu'à un
moment donné il ya une décision qui sera
prise
on a pas mal discuté un tous les deux
ans pendant pendant de longs mois
notamment sur le calendrier
ce calendrier était impossible à tenir
il faut se dire c'est ça dès lors qu'on
s'est arrêté fin octobre
là on est on est sain mars il arrive un
moment où ça ça ne passe plus et du coup
est ce que cette saison finalement de
recommencer en septembre cette saison
est ce que c'était logique
est-ce qu'on aurait peut-être dû annuler
cette saison dès le début peut-être
parce que certains ont fait que cinq six
matches finalement entre septembre et
fin octobre tout à fait alors bon c'est
vrai mais faut se souvenir de tout ce
qui s'est passé en octobre personne
n'imaginait que ça durerait jusqu'à que
ça durait encore aujourd'hui donc la
fédération a attendu attendu et puis il
arrive un moment où pas comme je le
disais ça passe plus il n'y a pas de
rügen du coup
ce lancement de saison si je peux dire
au mois de septembre quand la saison a
été lancée
les choses étaient différentes de ce
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
est ce que vous attendez un nombre une
baisse du nombre de licenciés en
septembre prochain
on parle de 1,7 millions de sportifs
licenciés en moins à la rentrée
prochaine
est ce que le football sera impacté et
ce qui sera impacté dans les yvelines à
votre avis alors déjà il est impacté
puisque nous avons au 15 mars 2021 nous
avons trois mille cinq cents licenciés
de moins que l'année dernière à la même
date
ça représente un peu moins de 1 thomas
9% ce qui est quand même sensible ce qui
est important de savoir c'est que sur
ses 3500 il y en a deux mille quatre
cent qui sont des jeunes qui ont entre 6
et 13 ans et ce qui est important pour
nous c'est qu'il faut bien comprendre
que ce sont les futurs licenciés ceux
qui resteront licencié ensuite et qui
grain et qui changeront de catégorie et
cédera donc on espère les récupérer
effectivement la saison prochaine on a
aussi perdu les pour la première fois
depuis des années des des licenciées
féminines on en a perdu à peu près 10%
donc nous espérons effectivement qu'à la
rentrée prochaine nous les licenciés
qu'on a perdu là on va les récupérer
vous vouliez parler du passeport c'est
bien ça non licenciés oui alors le
passeport c'est un une décision qui a
été prise par l'état il s'agit de 100
millions d'euros donc c'est pas rien ça
devrait toucher 1,8 million de
bénéficiaires les bénéficiaires c'est
des licenciés et il s'agit d'aider les
familles à payer le coût de la
cotisation dans un club sportif
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas très bien comment les choses
vont se passer on a parlé de 50 euros on
a parlé de 80 euros par personne je
parle des jeunes on nous dit que c'est
probablement les moins de 16 ans le maya
rien de définitif quand ça se passera on
sait pas encore très bien comment est ce
que ce sera un versement direct il sera
fait au club ou un versement qui sera
fait aux familles tout ça on sait pas
très bien
il ya quelques jours
l' agence nationale réunit son conseil
d'administration il paraît que c'est en
aidant un mécanisme en cours qui en
cours de finalisation
le problème c'est que il faut que ça
vienne vite parce que les premières
demandes de licence pourront se faire à
partir du 1er décembre du 1er juin
prochain 1er juin prochain c'est dans
deux mois donc il faut que d'ici là les
parents sachent si oui ou non ils seront
aidés pour payer la cotisation qui vont
devoir verser au club
s'ils réussissent effectivement il
demande une liste en île et demander une
licence pour vos enfants
alors on l'a vu lors de l' aventure de
conflans en coupe de france à la fin du
match ils ont tous dit que c'était une
famille que tout simplement ça leur
faisait plaisir d'être ensemble le soin
de s'entraîner ensemble de pouvoir faire
des matches ensemble
est ce que vous comprenez ce lien social
que le football apporte finalement à un
club
oui j'achète à dire sur le foot c'est
pas seulement taper dans un ballon et
gagner des matchs est aussi tout ce qui
gravite autour
effectivement les clubs au sein des
clubs
c'est un peu une famille effectivement
et c'est vrai que les depuis trop
longtemps maintenant
ce lien social n'existe quasiment plus
ou en tout cas il est très difficilement
les très difficile d'en avoir
c'est pour ça qu'on espère tous que ça
va repartir à la rentrée prochaine dans
de bonnes conditions
quel est l'état psychologique des clubs
des joueurs en ce moment est ce que je
sais vous si je n'ai pas mal
le district des yvelines dans quel état
ils sont ils ont ils ont un peu perdu
les jeunes ont pu continuer de
s'entraîner dans des conditions un petit
peu un petit peu difficile avec un
protocole sanitaire fort mais les et les
adultes les seniors eux ça a été
beaucoup plus compliquée je pense qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux ont perdu un
peu ce lien et ils ont hâte de le
retrouver
alors les partenaires aussi des
partenaires qui sont avec ces clubs tout
au long de la saison
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut jouer
sur les partenaires là la saison
prochaine
alors je pense que ça peut jouer
vis-à-vis des partenaires pour deux
raisons d'abord parce qu'effectivement
la saison s'est arrêtée mais aussi parce
que les partenaires c'est-à-dire ceux
qui aident les clubs et ben ils sont eux
mêmes dans une situation économique
compliquée est-ce que la d7 dlc gère le
gendarme du football financier sera
peut-être un peu plus clément votre avis
la dncg elle s'occupe des clubs d'un
certain niveau 1 ceux qui jouent à
partir à partir des compétitions
nationales mais
je pense qu'elle est il faudra bien
qu'elle tienne gronde lassés de la
situation mais je pense que les clubs
aussi vont devoir tenir compte de la
situation
ça sera vrai matip pour les clubs à
votre avis au niveau financier j'espère
que ce sera pas dramatique parce que les
clubs pendant toute cette saison il ya
un certain nombre de dépenses qui n'ont
pas fait qu'ils n'ont pas payé les
arbitres ils n'ont pas brillé les
déplacements ils n'ont pas payé en
partie leurs éducateurs s'ils étaient en
chômage partiel
il ya eu chômage partiel quand il était
salarié etc ceci étant dit ils ont aussi
perdu de leur recette la buvette les
fêtes les fêtes des clubs les tournois
etc
peut-être y aura-t-il quelques tournois
qui pourront se passer si la situation
permet de reprendre le foot non pas en
compétition mais en compétition tournoi
optiquement compétition club alors il
n'y a pas encore eu de décision par
rapport à la nationale 2 une division
dans laquelle évolue notamment poissy et
versailles on va justement écoutez
olivier cv du cles présidente fois ci à
ce sujet aujourd'hui
la problématique c'est quoi ton passe on
a un certain nombre de joueurs qui se
blesse puisque jésus vient de
communiquer que mon entraîneur pas plus
tard que ce matin à 10 heures comment
fait chaque semaine pour avoir le point
sur la situation les joueurs sont
démotivés une savent plus sur quel pied
danser
nous non plus d'ailleurs donc c'est même
plus de l'espoir s'est classé de
l'incertitude là je trouve que le temps
passe et compte tenu de la la situation
sanitaire je ne sais pas comment on
pourrait reprendre
vous comprenez l'énervement peut-être de
d'olive et ses musiques
je comprends tout à fait il reste
maintenant je ne pas pas de
des compétitions professionnelles mais
il ne reste maintenant que le national 2
qui s'interroge sur la question de
savoir ce qui va se passer toutes les
compétitions amateurs de niveau
inférieur sont toutes arrêtées mais
définitivement là elles sont pas
suspendues à sion t'arrêter et c'est
vrai que je me mets à la place dad
des clubs qui aujourd'hui se demande si
ça va prendre ou pas parce qu'ils sont
dans l'incertitude depuis le mois
d'octobre
ils ont un statut de semi professionnels
cette langue là il faut le préciser
c'est ça c'est parce qu'ils ont un
certain nombre de joueurs qui sont sous
contrat et qui sont des salariés
c'est pour cette raison qu'ils sont
traités de façon un peu différente et il
faut reprendre le championnat selon je
n'ai pas les éléments pour le dire mais
de toute façon on l'a vu avec la coupe
de france pour faire les matches de
coupe de france il y en a eu 1 31
janvier c'était conflent je peux vous
dire que c'était quand même compliqué il
fallait prendre pleins de précaution
faire des tests avant ça déteste le
matin même et c c'est quand même c'est
quand même très compliqué merci jean
pierre meurillon pour votre intervention
sur l'arrêt à des championnats amateurs
rester avec nous pour une dernière
information football je vous propose de
regarder à cette photo celle de nicolas
mercier edouard michu ce deux anciens de
la génération 2003 du fc versailles qui
se sont retrouvés en bretagne à
l'occasion d'un stage de l'équipe de
france 2010 8 nicolas mercier joue à
auxerre
edouard michelin joue avec le psg qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
jean-pierre le rayon eh bien ça
m'inspire que nous avons des clubs qu'il
travaille bien qui font beaucoup de qui
ont certes beaucoup de licenciés mais
qui ensuite font en sorte de s'entourer
de d'éducateurs compétents et c'est pas
une nouveauté versailles c'est déjà
arrivé peut il et d'autres d'autres
joueurs par le passé qu'ils sortent du
club de versailles le même bonheur par
exemple entre autres mais il y en a eu
depuis y en a eu d'autres qui sont qui
ont rejoint des des centres de formation
ensuite ils ont une iso ou non pas la
réussite et attendre mais en tout cas
effectivement versailles montre ce qu'il
faut faire quand on est un club de ce
niveau et ça se démontre aussi de cette
façon là il n'y a pas que les résultats
de l'équipe première il ya aussi ceux là
c'est à dire le fait des clubs recrutent
des très jeunes joueurs il est fort
m'enfin ils font ce qu'on appelle la
préformation et puis ensuite il son père
est dans un club professionnel et
ensuite
ils ont dans un centre de formation
c'est valorisant pour le club vous fait
plaisir bien sûr ça me fait plaisir bien
sûr merci à vous a dépassé sur ce
plateau on espère une saison 2021 2022
plus facile à gérer pour vous et pour le
district on continuera évidemment à vous
sollicitez sur tv à 78 hameau de volley
ball à présent dans le championnat élite
qui continue à se jouer en france le
club de conflans andrésy jouy s'est
inclinée ce week-end contre cesson saint
brieuc côtes d'armor à l'occasion de la
19e journée le score 3 sets à 2 25 20 19
25 18 25 25 12 et 11 15
cette défaite fait reculer les yvelinois
occasion ils sont désormais à la 4e
place prochain match samedi prochain
contre lyon toujours à domicile on va
maintenant ouvrir une page golf le
golfeur évinois antoine ros nord a
réalisé une belle performance au
championnat du monde de match-play à
austin au texas
des matches et un cours en un contre un
le pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles s'est brillamment imposé face
à l'un des favoris du tournoi le numéro
cinq mondial brayden 2 chambaud l'une
des stars sur le circuit américain le
français de 28 ans a ensuite perdu
contre l'anglais tommy fleetwood avant
de s'imposer dans son troisième match de
poule contre le sud-coréen 6 ou kim des
résultats insuffisants pour sortir des
poules mais le golfeur yvelinois s'est
fait un nom dans lors de ce tournoi
le 64e mondiale devrait encore monter en
haut classement dans l'est à prochaines
semaines on continue à parler golf il ya
un peu plus d'une semaine l'illinois
charlotte duty a remporté l'une de ces
de ses plus belles victoires sur le
circuit international en gagnant des
internationaux d'italie dames la joueuse
de saint nom la bretèche veut continuer
sa progression à presque 22 ans pour
entrer dans le cercle des meilleures
joueuses du circuit dans les prochaines
années
son portrait un montage de rémi lefebvre
à 21 ans elle fait partie des golfeuses
à suivant cette année 2021 charlotte
liothier vient de remporter les
internationaux d'italie dame ce 21 mars
dutoit important dans sa jeune carrière
c'est une guitare qui m'a procuré
beaucoup d'émotion parce que parce que
c'était pas une victoire qui était qui a
été annoncé avant et je me suis vraiment
battu pour pour gagner et
et quand on travaille beaucoup qu'on se
bat et que là
à l'accomplissement de gagner ça arrive
c'est magnifique
en soulevant la coupe charlotte liothier
c'est sûrement remémorer ces dix
dernières années de golf à haut niveau
la sportive a débuté sur les greens à
l'âge de 12 ans à la réunion avant de
quitter son île en 2014 pour rejoindre
la métropole
aujourd'hui la golf s'épanouit dans cet
écrin saint nom la bretèche depuis plus
de deux ans c'est un club que je ne
connaissais pas du tout honnêtement mai
auquel je tiens beaucoup maintenant
parce que tout le monde est gentil avec
moi depuis toujours
les infrastructures sont bien il ya deux
par course et c'est vraiment bien pour
pouvoir s'entraîner parce qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de golf qui ont deux
parcours
il ya des zones d'entraînement qui sont
quand même très bien et qui sont très
bien entretenus des infrastructures de
haut niveau qui vont lui permettre
d'accomplir l'un de ses premiers
objectifs passé professionnel en fin
d'année une première étape pour viser
ses plus grands rêves numéro 1 mondiale
parce que parce que bah c'est un peu
dans ma tête c'est un peu un objectif à
un rêve aussi surtout c'est d'avoir plus
personne devant soi et désire bas je
suis la plus forte du monde pendant un
temps mais je le suis et et c'est
vraiment un rêve
autres objectifs envisagés dans les
prochaines années par charlotte liothier
les jeux olympiques et pourquoi pas ceux
de 2024 golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
à 21 ans l'avenir lui appartient le
département des yvelines est aussi une
terre de rugby a féminin un véritable
vivier pour les clubs de l'élite c'est
le cas pour les pinkroccade du stade
français à paris plusieurs rugbywoman du
club parisien sans passer par des
équipes yvelinoise rend compte avec
marisa luz au demi de mêlée à parisienne
et clotilde de l'embarqué 3 et mines des
pink york est ce un reportage de nicolas
doré originaire de chevreuse marisa
l'uso est une pique roquettes depuis
2010 9 elle joue demi de mêlée dans
l'équipe féminine du stade français
paris en élite une le plus haut niveau
du rugby féminin l'ovalie elle l'a dans
le sang son père a présidé le club de
chevreuse et ses frères ont joué au
rugby chevreuse à une petite ville de
campagne où tout
l'école élémentaire tout le monde fait
aussi pratique du rugby tout le monde se
connaît donc du coup de bouche à oreille
avec les copains forcément envie d'y
prendre goût donc du coup on tente
éducatrice spécialisée de profession
marisa l'uso organise son planning pour
être la plus performante elle a eu la
chance d'être sélectionné en équipe de
france lors du tournoi des six nations
en 2010 9 à l'époque j'étais assistant
d'éducation donc acheté dans le bureau
et je reçois la paix joie qui est ce
qu'est ce que c'était c'était pendant la
patte du tournoi des six nations
donc du coup je me pose des questions et
donc du coup bas milk héros la manager
actuel m'appelle et me fais la
proposition de participer à un stage et
de regroupement avec le 15 pour la
semaine de l'italie 2e ou 3e ligne au
stade français paris clotilde embarré
est arrivé en 2016
avant cela elle a joué à la mls gp
maisons laffitte saint germain poissy
une équipe où elle a développé ses
capacités rugbystique
c'est mon premier club d'adultes entre
guillemets donc c'était énormément de
découverte mais que des coupes découvert
positive avec des j'ai énormément de
chance parce que je suis tombé sur des
coaches qui m'ont tout de suite fait
confiance c'est que des moments hyper
hyper riches ou chanteur qui a vraiment
du soutien de la part du club vis-à-vis
des féminines ce qui n'est pas forcément
le cas dans tant d'autres clubs
l'équipe féminine du stade français a
été créé il ya une dizaine d'années les
potentiels sont repérés dans les clubs
franciliens
c'était le cas pour marissa l'uso et
clotilde de l'an barre et déjà ces deux
joueuses très travailleuse
très exigeante avec elle même qui adore
travailler donc venir venir faire des
séances au quotidien que ce soit en
salle de musculation
que ce soit le mardi et le jeudi sur le
terrain que ce soit le mercredi sur des
séances spécifiques elles sont toujours
présentes très à l'écouté
au niveau sportif marisa l'uso et
clotilde embarré sont engagés avec les
pink roquette dans la course au maintien
cette saison pour pouvoir conserver leur
place en élite une
on va terminer par du tennis le deuxième
français à l'arrêt
arthur rinderknecht était la semaine
dernière au tournoi challenger de lille
les sportifs de 25 ans a fait a plutôt
une bonne impression arriver dans une
forme qui n'était pas forcément
optimales l'illinois originaire de saint
germain en laye a réussi à se hisser en
quarts de finale du tournoi il a perdu
contre maxime janvier sur le score de
6-4 7-6 alors sur l'airé noc neige reste
127e mondial il va commencer sa
préparation en vue de roland garros qui
se déroulera au mois de mai et on vient
d'avoir avec nous à l'instant en visio
benjamin thomas on va parler du coût de
2 cyclisme sur piste benjamin thomas
vous êtes actuellement en stage au
vélodrome nationale 2 50 en ligne je
rappelle vous êtes champion du monde de
l'omnium à deux reprises vous avez 25
ans et vous êtes du coup avec nous enfin
alors j'imagine que vous êtes ravi
d'être au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
benjamin thomas c'est un grand plaisir
de retrouver le vélodrome voilà c'est ça
a été particulier ces derniers temps
l'année dernière avec avec la crise
sanitaire
et puis voilà on se retrouve cette
semaine en stage avec plus de l'équipe
de france dans un contexte un peu
particulier
le vélodrome a été reconvertie en
vaccinodromes donc voilà on s'entraîne
avec les gens qui seront vaccinées au
milieu mais on est heureux de pouvoir
continuer notre activité notre
préparation pour pour tokyo est ce que
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs peut-être
benjamin thomas vous avez gagné l'or aux
championnats d'europe en 2016 c'est bien
ça oui oui on a on a vécu des monts bon
moment sur ce vélodrome
il y aura les championnats du monde
l'année prochaine en 2022 qui seront
organisées ici
et puis forcément on pense aussi aux jo
de paris dans trois ans donc voilà c'est
un
au vélodrome qui est une des plus belles
installations au monde pour pratiquer le
cyclisme sur piste et c'était votre lieu
d'entraînement également pendant
plusieurs années
oui tout à fait j'ai vécu pendant trois
ans dans les yvelines
donc je m'y entraîner régulièrement et
une installation complète voilà avec une
salle de musculation des salles pour la
récupération balnéothérapie et puis une
piste voilà qui permet de s'entraîner
dans les meilleures conditions et à quoi
sert ce stage finalement ça sert de
préparation on prépare les automatismes
peut-être ouais voilà on se retrouve
avec on est un collectif de huit
coureurs avec trois coureurs pour la
halle et qui seront le groupe pour les
jeux olympiques
donc on sera aligné sur l'omnium et
l'américaine donc nous on travaille
voilà les courses les courses en peloton
et puis de l'autre côté il ya aussi
également de poursuite qui même s'il
n'est pas qualifié pour premiers jeux
olympiques près par ceux de paris donc
on est un peu divisés en deux groupes
ceux qui préparent les jeux de tokyo et
puis ceux qui préparent ceux de paris et
la suite est-ce que c'est aussi
l'occasion peut-être de parler avec les
entraîneurs
oui oui c'est c'est le moment d'échangés
de se retrouver de faire le point mettre
en place ces derniers les derniers
entraînements les derniers stages avant
l'échéance olympique
et puis ça permet de faire une revue
d'effectif et de revoir tout le monde ça
fait ça fait du bien parce que voilà
pour une année à s'entraîner quasiment
seul chez soi ça fait du bien de
retrouver l'équipe de france
comment vous analysé cette équipe de
france d'endurance est ce que le niveau
est bon en vue des jo wil on est en
train de monter en puissance petit à
petit voilà en a on ambitionne le podium
faire les disciplines au roi sera aligné
sur le sprint également l'équipe
l'équipe en train de bien revenir donc
voilà on ira à tokyo avec des ambitions
et puis on monte petit à petit en tant
que nature et la forme la forme arrive
alors vous avez 25 ans vous avez été
trois fois champion du monde deux fois
de l'omnium je le disais précédemment et
une fois de l'américaine cinq fois
champion d'europe et quatre fois
champion de france on a un petit peu
l'impression que tout vous réussit
benjamin thomas ouais c'est vrai j'ai un
gros palmarès sur la piste mais voilà je
m'y attarde pas forcément moi je pense
je vais vraiment beaucoup de l'avant
donc je regarde plus les échéances des
futures échéances
et voilà tout ce qui manque c'est
participer aux jeux olympiques et puis
remporter une médaille ou un titre donc
j'espère avoir la même réussite que
celle que j'ai eue sur le début de ma
carrière et puis continuer je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de raison il n'y a pas
de raison que ça ne marche pas et puis
voilà je mets je met tout en place
et puis la fédération nous soutiennent
dans l'est dans les meilleures
conditions pour vous pour y arriver donc
je suis dans les meilleures conditions
pour cet objectif et continuer continuer
ma carrière et réussir comme cela où j
guzzo ku se serait alors forcément
l'objectif oui après voilà il faut pas
partir en se disant qu'on a déjà gagné
forcément j'aurais une étiquette de
favoris et ça sera compliqué sur des
courses en peloton de courir avec cette
étiquette cette pancarte dans le dos
comme on dit dans le vélo mais mais
voilà ça sera la et qui sera plus
fort et je vais tout faire pour
pour me préparer au mieux et puis voilà
j'ai dû quand même de l'expérience dans
je commence à avoir de l'expérience à
ces disciplines
donc je peux déjà ambitionner le podium
et puis voilà alors ça serait le la
cerise sur le gâteau donc on verra bien
comment fait justement pour gérer ce
statut de favori
eh ben c'est oui c'est bon je veux dire
qu'il ya pas vraiment grand-chose à dire
pas grand chose à faire quand il faut
juste rester soi même courir comme on le
fait d'habitude et pas se mettre la
pression on pas se mettre de pression
supplémentaire rester calme dans des
dans certaines situations voilà quand on
est observé par ses adversaires
on est un peu plus surveillé que
d'autres forcément des fois ça peut être
grisant où on peut faire des commettre
des erreurs
et justement il faut il faut garder la
tête froide et courir avec beaucoup de
sang froid et la maîtrise pour pour au
final réussir à l'emporter même si même
si on est surveillé alors cet été la
course à l'américaine fera son retour au
programme olympique
est ce que ça change quelque chose pour
vous non parce que ces dernières années
j'ai toujours été habitué à courir les
deux disciplines que ce soit l'omnium
l'américaine donc c'est vrai que ça
manquait vraiment programme cette
américaine une discipline une discipline
historique de la biste la cire
disparition voilà santé qui manquait
quelque chose au programme des jeux donc
s'efforcer pékin en 2008 un jeu je
précise
ouais ouais la dernière fois c'était en
2008 donc ça fait plaisir de la
retrouver c'est une discipline où en
france on a de très bons coureurs et on
est une très bonne école de l'américaine
avec des coureurs d'expérience des
jeunes courant également qu'ils ont une
soif d'apprendre
donc ça va c'est un grand plaisir de la
retrouver et puis voilà ce sera une
course très disputée et sûrement un peu
plus aléatoire que l'omnium mais mon
espère également décroché voilà un
podium dans cette discipline ça serait
vraiment l'objectif
l'objectif serait remplie vous serez
avec morgane technique ce qui alors les
sélections sont pas tout à fait défini
encore voilà on est un collectif de
quatre coureurs avec morgan kneisky de
narbonne grondin et kevin vauquelin donc
les prochaines les prochaines
compétitions on aura ces mois ci
permettront aux sélectionneurs d'affiner
la d'affiner la sélection et puis voilà
entre morgan qui a l'expérience et kevin
et donavan qui sont de jeunes coureurs
mais voilà très fort physiquement et qui
ont très envie
voilà l'émulation amènera forcément
avoir une belle équipe au départ à tokyo
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour ces prochains mois
monsieur et et voilà que les courses les
coupes du monde les compétitions soit
ait lieu donc qui permettent de se
préparer dans la
de la meilleure des façons et puis et
puis sinon voilà la santé c'est le
principal surtout en cette période et
après voilà le reste le reste viendra
tout seul entre guillemets merci à vous
benjamin thomas bon courage pour les
prochains mois on espère vous voir aux
jo de tokyo l'été prochain et pourquoi
pas avec une médaille d'or autour du cou
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]